baby don't go in there
oh my god
we're all very happy to happy early I
imagine that's not exactly true doctor
this is the weather so corporate I'm
just looking for some information about
Morgan Morgan was a third attempt issue
our little breakthrough it's the next
step in evolution
it's bioengineered with synthetic DNA
within a month walking and talking in
six months big cities not wildest
expectations
I'd like to discuss the incident if
that's okay
she had a tantrum there was joy in her
heart before we shoved her back in that
box you're feeling a little sad Morgan
yes do you like it here
yes do you like about it I like my
friends do you think they treat you like
a friend I mean you think it's normal
for friends to lock each other in cages
what would you do if I recommended that
you should not be allowed to leave this
row
okay if I recommended that you be
terminated we should end this answer me
what what you do where's Marion
initiating lockdown what you don't
understand
Morgan is still evolving the people in
this house are in danger eight it needs
to be terminated
seven six five five four
I'm starting to feel like myself the
Assassin's Creed universe is a cinematic
experience the action sequences are
massive
I just wanted to be